- I would let Jamie Foxx ruin my life
and make me a single mother.
(laughing)
'Cause I'm a mother (beep).
(rhythmic gentle music)
The best onscreen performance in the
movie Django goes to Jamie Foxx's penis.
Damn, that thing was pretty.
Well, let me show you
something, God damn it.
(beep)
Won the Oscar and the Oscar Meyer.
What you think is at the
bottom of this, mother (beep)?
I had to (beep) in two parts.
Carry the base here and the tip in here.
That's my new album too,
called Just the Tip.
♪ Just the tip and nuts ♪
♪ You and I ♪
Just the tip and nuts.
You know that feeling
when you're so horny,
only Jamie Foxx will do?
(chuckling)
(beep) and I come on all
different speeds too.
I come to you, baby.
Rapid fire!
Huh, you wanna get it, you
wanna smoke a cigarette after?
Grab a package of Pall
Malls and some Gibson gin.
I need a sugar daddy that
looks just like Jamie Foxx.
Baby, I got so much sugar.
Take you insulins, baby,
'cause you gonna get diabetes
once I lay this sugar in your veins.
♪ Sugar in your veins ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ With your stinkin' (beep) ♪
That's coming out on iTunes.
I would lick Jamie Foxx all over, tbfh.
Get ready, you know what I'm saying?
Get all the caverns, make
sure you got your GPS,
find the right spots.
Waze.
Takin' Waze, I went through
somebody's living room.
Took a left and, "My
bad, y'all eating (beep).
Just trying to get to the Hollywood Boul."
I'm gonna come up with Love Waze
so you know how to find your
partner, what they like.
I want Jamie Foxx to sing something to me
between my T-H-I, nevermind.
Thighs?
It would be like this.
♪ Baby I'm ♪
♪ In between your ♪
You gotta lift your thighs, girl.
♪ Thighs ♪
Anyway, oh, (beep) Jamie Foxx is
hosting the 2018 BET Awards.
Mother (beep) right, we're about to
have an incredible time.
Barrack Obama's coming to the BET Awards
and if there's any indication that
America needs me back ASAP.
We're gonna have Oprah, Oprah Winfrey!
This is Jay-Z.
I started off in the Marcy Projects,
it's crazy, my man, Beyonce, it's crazy.
He gonna be at the BET Awards.
Last thirst tweet, the part in Django
when Jamie Foxx saved Kerry from the room
and he said, "It's my
baby," "It's my baby,"
in his sexy voice.
Yes, baby, save me, yes.
I'm here to save you, baby.
Captain Save 'em All,
that's what I wanna do,
and you can find my new
record, Tip and Balls,
wait, what was it, Tip and Nuts?
The Tip and Balls is the European release.
(gentle instrumental music)